when we were doing no country you know
everything was pretty much drawn and you
kind of knew what you were doing and it
was it was not dialogue heavy so there
wasn't a lot of stuff to experiment with
and change but I know when I got the
satchel and I opened it up I said don't
you think he should say something he
looks at the Dead Guy and then he looks
around and you know you can tell he's
thinking about what is this what do I
want to do with this and shouldn't there
be like a little something there and Joe
goes well like what I said I don't know
like a huh or like a hmm and they go is
there anything else and I go like like
and they go what else and then now
you're thinking you're [ __ ] with me
right so I went through about six of
them and they go and Ethan said try the
second one so I did the second one
whatever's in there
and then every time we screen the movie
Once the movie was finished I always
knew where Ethan was in the theater
because every time that moment happened
he would burst out laughing
so was it a joke or did it help the
movie and the scene